Okay so, we've looked at the CSS, we've looked at the HTML files.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But there's a lot more going on in here. So how,
I mean, how do you think about approaching a new program like this?
>> Well, so there's always going to be some
files, these guys that have a point of
for, of being there but they aren't really
essential to understanding the functionality of the program.
>> Okay.
>> So, I sort of ignore those guys and go straight for the,
you know, the things that really change
how the program looks and how it operates.
>> Okay.
>> So, if we look here in the JavaScript, we'll see a bunch of, a bunch of files
including some that are, you know, sort of less
useful when it comes to understanding how the programs works.
>> Okay. So like, here we are in the
JavaScript file we have here. Add in frame, underscore poly-fill.
>> Okay, so this, this guy isn't really going to give
you a lot of information about how the game functions.
>> How do you know that?
>> You can just sort of look. There's not really a lot happening here that has
to do with, like, the tiles on the,
on the page moving around or anything like that.
It's just sort of something you have to get a feel for. So this, this guy
seems to be doing something, it's creating a
game manager, which sounds like something to do with
the game. So that's probably defined in here.
>> Okay, and looks like it is.
>> And it looks like this guy has a lot of functions that do
stuff with the game. So this, this is probably a good place to start looking.
>> Okay.
>> At what the overall structure of the program looks like.
>> And then just keep going from
there until you're satisfied that you understand
things? Okay, so I know you took some time to make a pretty thing.
I want to pull it up. I'm lying. This is my handwriting. I
did it for you, sorry. [LAUGH] But these are the big, these are
the big files that you were, the most important in terms of
function of the game. The index, the main file, the whole JavaScript folder.
>> With a couple of exceptions. Yeah.
>> Things that weren't quite as important.
>> The poly fill functions
>> Mm-hm.
>> Or files especially. And then these seven, these seven files so if, if
you were going to do, I am sorry these seven JavaScript files, yeah. So if
we were going to add an Undo button, I mean,
where is the majority of the work going to take place?
Would it be in the Index, would it be in
the Main, or would it be somewhere in these JavaScript files?